when I was 13 years old I was little kid
skiing in New Hampshire and I dreamed of
figuring out how to ski every single day
and here we are now 25 years later I've
spent thousands and thousands of hours
both on the slopes and out training
would stay at the top of the food chain
I spend my life traveling all over the
world two big mountains and do a lot of
dangerous things but there's nothing
like coming home to my backyard right
here in Aspen Snowmass I mean this is my
happy place this is my my natural
habitat the mountains here and ready to
get it on today we're gonna get out hit
the trails and then catch some music
it's jazz Aspen Snowmass when I'm out on
the trails or out skiing that's when I'm
the most calm the most happy way that
makes sense to have a career of fun but
you know what everybody should follow
their passions and that's all I tried to
do and I tried to figure out how I could
make a job or a business or a career out
of that so far has been successful at it
and I'm very fortunate to just want to
be out there every day having a good
time with it
hello okay hey Chris what's up uh-huh
I'm at the top of the cliff right now we
go away really cool I won't keep you hey
I got the tickets for Jazz Aspen tonight
okay cool
I'll be right down
all right let's go see some music one of
the things that we as asked the locals
are so privileged to have is jazz Aspen
Snowmass this fantastic music festival
that takes place every Labor Day weekend
but since 25th year we get a list fans
every single year here and it's sort of
one of the highlights of the summer hey
Jim man I'm so excited to be here 25
years ago what was going through your
mind to create jazz Aspen so in the
summer of 1989 I put together a tour of
jazz festivals all over Europe within 24
hours of being there I was like this is
it I came home and I said I'm gonna try
to start a Jazz Festival in Aspen and I
gave myself five years I said I'm still
standing in five years it's still
standing it might make it and then the
rest of this
Jim we'll see you out there thank you so
much best wishes for an awesome weekend
okay thanks
thank you so much for soldiering through
yeah it's pretty much perfect day today
you know mother nature threw a little
rain in there that doesn't bother us
mountain people we got to end it if jazz
asked it's no mess
what could be any better than that